Ren, you're here,
Ryuko
[Music] You're
making me into a horse, too. I'm
getting stronger, so my desires are limitless. Here I am,
awakening to even more strength, and defeating you
[applause].
Awakening to power, winning everything,
collecting all the equipment, increasing all the powers, being the thief of all,
this scum who seeks victory and seeks power is greedy, but
why is it that I feel so miserable and small?
Anyway, those eyes look at me.  The Curse
series has a skill that makes you pay a price every time you use it.If you do
n't stop it quickly, you
can't beat me, but you can tell me what happened to your
friend Bit.
[Music]
Looks like your father showed up.
I'll be in trouble if you forget that I'm a noisy person who's not your enemy. Dad, are you going to do it? You should stand back, calm down, you're the
leader of the thieves. No matter what you
say, I'll punish you for that foolish crime.  I don't
even have time to scream, and I despair at the separation of our bodies, but I'm
kidding you.
Don't get close to me.